[Musique]
avec Michel d'abord cet accident survenu
en fin de matinée qui a très fortement
impacté la circulation sur l'autoroute à
12 un accident impressionnant s'est
produit en fin de matinée sur
l'autoroute à la jonction de la 12 en
direction de la province dans le virage
juste avant la ligne droite qui longe
l'aérodrome de saint-ciier l'école un
poids lourd a perdu le contrôle et s'est
retrouvé en équilibre sur le parapé
l'arrière du véhicule suspendu au-dessus
de la chaussée une voie a été fermée
pendant plusieurs he pour permettre
l'intervention des secours créant
d'importants bouchons à 17h la route a
finalement été rouverte pour le plus
grand bonheur des automobiliste voilà
pour cet accident à la jonction de la 12
avec la 13 petite pensée à notre
collègue Clara de Frutos qui est resté
bloqué pendant plusieurs heures dans ce
cet accident alors l'image marquante du
weekend justement Michel on en parlait
dans les titres plus de 100000 personnes
ont défilé ce dimanche à Paris lors de
la marche contre l'antisémitisme en tête
de cortège deux ivelinois il y a PIV et
Gérard Larché uni contre l'antisémitisme
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
ilelle Bron Pivet et le président du
Sénat Gérard Larché ont mené ce dimanche
le cortège de la Marche pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme
dont ils sont à l'initiative à leur côté
de nombreux élus ivelinois était
également présent notamment la sénatrice
Martha de Sidrac ou encore le député de
la 12e circonscription Carl olive
plusieurs maire du département ont aussi
fait le déplacement parmi eux Pascal
tevno le maire de Vézy vill coublé me
semblait important euh de rappeler à la
fois notre
attachement aux valeurs de la République
moi j'étais agrable al pas surpris mais
satisfait euh qu'il a beaucoup de monde
et
surtout que ça soit une marche sereine
digne avec des des champs de la
Marseillaise un respect de chacun
finalement les républicains les Français
les citoyens qui se retrouvai pour euh
bah dire qu'ils étaient attachés au de
la République et que l'antisémitisme
n'avait pas sa place l'objectif de cette
marche réaffirmer la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme depuis le début de la
guerre en contre entre Israël et le
Hamas plus de 1200 actes anti-juifs ont
été recensés en France la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale yel Bron pivé a
également été victime de ces actes
antisémites toujours dans ce contexte de
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas un appel
à la paix au cesser lefeu était organisé
samedi du côté des Mureaux près de 300
personnes ont manifesté pour la paix à
Gaza ce samedi organisé par le collectif
blouse blanche et liberté fondamentale
la manifestation avait pour but de
soutenir les Palestiniens victimes du
conflit mais aussi les civils juifs et
les chrétiens orthodoxes ont veut la
paix pour tout le monde on scander les
manifestants à politique et citoyenne la
manifestation n'avait pas pour but de
contrer le rassemblement contre
l'antisémitisme de dimanche à Paris on
reste au Murau au Murau tout autre chose
Michel demain le Salon honomie Habitat
ouvre ses portes au public alors vous
connaissiez certainement le salon
itonomy mais cette année c'est la
première édition du Salon itonomie
Habitat le thème du salon cette année un
habitat inclusif pour les personnes
âgées ou porteuses de handicap l'habitat
est aujourd'hui perçu comme un facteur
décisif de la qualité de vie le salon
est organisé par le département des
imines ainsi que le département des
Hautes scèes dans le but de promouvoir
un habitat accessible et adapté à tous
le salon réunira près de 40 exposants
déclinés en quatre univers les
aménagements les services et la vie
sociale les solutions d'habitat service
et les financements pour les intéressés
rendez-vous mardi 14 novembre d 9h à
l'oxygène Factory des Murau et puis à
Chantelou Levine les restos du cœur ont
investi leurs nouveaux locaux l'antenne
locale des Restos du cœur a inauguré ce
nouveau ces nouveaux locaux aménagé par
la ville il se situe rue d'andrésie dans
l'ancien Carrefour Contact après
plusieurs déménagements ces dernières
années l'association a enfin son adresse
définitive et un bâtiment flamban neuf
avec ses nouveaux locaux les
bénéficiaires de l'association et les
bénévoles pour pouront profiter de
meilleures conditions d'accueil avec un
réfectoire un bureau administratif ainsi
que des vestiaires l'association est
aujourd'hui présente dans une vingtaine
de communes ivinoises merci Michel et si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les ivelines n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag set news